bien mes chers collègues je joue sont
heureux de vous retrouver dans
l'hémicycle
après une longue période d'interruption
la séance est donc ouverte
ne compte rendu intégral de la séance du
23 mars voyez ce qui nous sépare du 23
mars à aujourd'hui a été publié sur
notre site internet nous n'avons pas
reçu
d'observation il y en aurait-il en
séance
je n'en vois pas le procès verbal est
donc adopté
j'ai reçu de madame la première ministre
communication du décret de monsieur
président de la république en date du 28
juin 2022 portant convocation du
parlement en session extraordinaire
acte est donnée de cette communication
ce décret qui vous a été adressée a été
publié sur notre site
en conséquence la session extraordinaire
est désormais ouverte
en application de l'article lots 320 du
code électoral le mandat sénatorial
de jean-baptiste lemoyne a repris le
mardi 21 juin 2022 à zéro heure en
conséquence le mandat sénatorial de
madame marie evrard a cessé le lundi 20
juin à minuit je salue le retour de
notre collègue jean baptiste lemoyne
dans notre hémicycle
par lettre en date du 1er juillet 2022
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur m'a
fait connaître qu'en application de
l'article et le aux 320 du code
électoral monsieur daniel rouhier est
appelé à remplacer en qualité de
sénateur du val de marne madame sophie
tailler polian est démissionnaire à la
suite de son élection à l'assemblée
nationale j'ai d'ailleurs écrit à ma
table phi thai et polluants à la fois
qu'on s'a l'vé son élection il a
remercié
le mandat de
daniel breuiller a commencé ce lundi 4
juillet 2022 à 0 heure au nom du sénat
je lui souhaite la bienvenue parmi nous
[Applaudissements]
profitez-en ça n'arrive pas tous les
jours comme ça
j'informe le sénat que des candidatures
pour siéger au sein de la commission des
affaires économiques de la commission
des finances et de la commission des
affaires européennes ont été publiés
ces candidatures seront ratifiés si la
présidence n'a pas reçu d'opposition
dans le délai d'une heure prévue par
notre règle
j'adore mais c'est là que conformément à
l'article 12 bis alina 9 et 10 de notre
règlement notre collègue alain richard
est devenu vice président du sénat le
1er avril dernier en remplacement de
notre collègue georges patient et c'est
la première fois qu'ils siègent ainsi
dans les dents les miss it
je souhaite à nouveau remercier georges
patient pour la manière dont il a exercé
cette fonction de vice président et sa
contribution aux travaux du bureau
j'informe également le sénat que
conformément à l'article 8 de notre
règlement notre collègue jean pierre
corbisez devenu membre 17 juin dernier
de la commission des affaires
européennes
j'ai le regret de chers collègues de
vous faire part depuis notre réunion du
23 mars du décès d'un certain nombre
d'anciens collègues
michel delebarre qui fut sénateur du
nord de 2011 2017 notre collègue
dominique mortemousque qui fut sénateur
de la dordogne de 2002 à 2008 de notre
collègue jean faure qui fut sénateur de
l'isère de 1983 à 2011 et de notre
collègue yves en renard et qui fut
sénateur de
1985 à 2009 qui fut aussi secrétaire du
bureau du sénat nous observerons un bref
moment de recueillement en mémoire de
jean faure et nos trois autres collègues
au début de la séance des questions
d'actualité
le 13 juillet prochain
l'anrs jour appelle la lecture d'une
déclaration
du gouvernement je voudrais saluer la
présence au banc du gouvernement
de nombreux ministres se leur souhaiter
la cordiale bienvenue certains
connaissent les musiques d'autres ne
connaissent pas ou ont connu d'autres
hémicycle donc qu'il soit ici les les
bienvenus dans cet
hémicycle du sénat je vais maintenant
donner la parole à monsieur bruno le
maire ministre de l'économie des
finances et de la souveraineté
industrielle et numérique qui va donc
procéder à la lecture de cette
déclaration devant le sénat monsieur le
ministre
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
comme la tradition le veut j'ai
l'honneur de m'adresser devant vous pour
vous faire part d'un déclaration de
politique générale de la première
ministre que la première ministre lit
actuellement devant l'assemblée
nationale
en m'adressant à vous c'est à la france
que je parle
chacune de vos circonscriptions
porte une parcelle de notre histoire et
des défis qui s'ouvre devant nous
chacun de vos territoires
exprime une réalité de notre pays de ses
craintes et de ses espoirs
nous aurons tous l'ampleur de la tâche
les français à protéger la république à
défendre notre pays a rassemblé la
planète à préserver
c'est le sens de l'action du président
de la république depuis cinq ans c'est
notre mission collective au gouvernement
comme sur ces bancs
avec vous avec tous les gouvernements
avec nos concitoyens
nous réussirons j'y suis déterminé
ces dernières semaines à quatre reprises
les françaises et les français se sont
exprimés
par le résultat des urnes
ils nous demandent d'agir et d'agir
autrement
par leur message ils nous demandent de
prendre collectivement nos
responsabilités nous le forment
ensemble nous répondrons adecco de
l'abstention est le signe d'une
démocratie malade d'un désarroi de la
jeunesse d'une perte de confiance dans
notre capacité à changer des vies
ensemble nous répondrons à la demande
d'actions c'est celle qui s'exprime le
plus fortement dans le vote des français
ne pouvons pas décevoir
ensemble
nous répondrons à l'exigence de
responsabilité
les français ont élu une assemblée sans
majorité absolue il nous invite à des
pratiques nouvelles un dialogue soutenu
et à la recherche active de compromis
le contexte nous oblige la guerre en
ukraine aux portes de l'europe nous
rappelle combien la paix est fragile les
prix de l'énergie augmentent et nous
devons continuer à protéger les français
l'épidémie est toujours là notre
vigilance doit rester total l'urgence
écologique se fait chaque seconde plus
pressante et nous avons un devoir
d'action
l'insécurité inquiète peu concitoyens et
brise encore des vies et des destins
nous devons le dire aussi dans les
dernières semaines avec la guerre qui
dure notre situation économique s'est
assombri nos perspectives de croissance
des grades les taux d'intérêt augmentent
quant à nos finances publiques elles
doivent reprendre le chemin de
l'équilibré
face à de tels défis le désordre et
l'instabilité ne sont pas des options
nous ne sommes peut être pas d'accord
sur toutes les solutions mais nous avons
toutes et tous conscience de l'urgence
et de la nécessité d'agir
les français nous demandent de nous
parler plus de nous parler mieux est de
construire ensemble
je veux qu ensemble nous redonnions un
sens et une vertus au mot compromis
depuis trop longtemps oublié notre vie
politique
le compromis
ce n'est pas se compromettre
c'est accepté chacun de faire un pas
vers l'autre
cela ne signifie nullement l'effacement
de différences ou le renoncement de
conviction les clivages existent et ils
continueront à exister
bâtir ensemble ne signifie pas renoncer
à son identité
la mienne vous le savez a pour socle
inaltérable les valeurs notre république
la liberté
l'égalité la fraternité et la laïcité
mon identité c'est une france plus forte
dans une europe plus indépendante c'est
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
toujours tout le temps c'est le respect
de la laïcité sans accommodements ni
compromission c'est le refus opposé des
uns aux autres et de désigner des boucs
émissaires
c'est le courage de dire la vérité aux
français
c'est fort de ces convictions
des valeurs que je chéris et protège
comme citoyen comme élu que je crois
souhaitable et possible que chaque
conviction sac idées puissent être
défendus débattu et s'il le faut
combattre
trop longtemps notre vie politique n'a
été faite que deux blocs qui
s'affrontent
il est temps d'entrer dans l'ère des
forces qui bâtissent ensemble
une majorité relative n'est pas et ne
sera pas le synonyme d'une action
relative elle n'est pas et ne sera pas
le signe de l'impuissance
rappelons nous qu'en 1958 les gaullistes
ne sont pas majoritaires à l'assemblée
nationale quand la vème république
connaît ses premières heures et crée les
chu et l'assurance chômage
rappelons nous que c'est le gouvernement
rocard qui l'avait pourtant qu'une
majorité relative sur ses bancs qu'à
créer le rmi la csg et lancer le
processus de paix en nouvelle calédonie
nous avons encore des droits à conquérir
des progrès à réaliser des protections à
bâtir s'ils y sont parvenus nous y
parviendrons
ces dernières semaines le président de
la république est garant de nos
institutions et moi même avons consultés
et écoutés nous vous avons proposé
plusieurs manières de faire pour
l'urgence comme pour les années à venir
le résultat de nos échanges est clair
une nouvelle page de notre histoire
politique et parlementaire commence
celle des majorités de projets avec son
gouvernement la première ministre sera
l'infatigable bâtisseuse je sais combien
nous sommes attendus
et nous ne nous déroberons pas ni devant
les défis ni devant les débats nous
croyons aux trois choses l'écoutent
l'action et les résultats nous n'avons
qu'une seule boussole qui sera celle du
gouvernement bâtir pour notre pays le
gouvernement ne sera jamais celui des
clivages factice et des idées toutes
faites car je crois fermement au
dépassement entamé il ya cinq ans par le
président de la république
pour chaque sujet nous mènerons une
concertation danse nous aborderons
chaque texte dans un esprit de dialogue
et de compromis et d'ouverture
nous nous inscrirons dans le cadre des
valeurs portées par le projet du
président de la république
la première ministre l'a dit aux
présidents de groupe de l'assemblée
nationale nous sommes prêts à entendre
les propositions de chacun en débattre
et si nous en partageons les objectifs
et des valeurs à amender notre projet
cette méthode de travail nous devons
l'incarner pour réfléchir collectivement
à l'avenir et aux évolutions de nos
institutions
sous l'égide du président de la
république une commission transpartisane
sera lancé à la rentrée pour y parvenir
cette méthode nous devrons apporter au
delà des murs de cette assemblée nous
associerons davantage les élus locaux à
nos réflexions et à nos décisions ils
sont le ciment d'un frais public
nous devons laisser des marges de
manoeuvre aux territoires
car c'est dans les solutions
différenciées que se trouvent les
résultats concrets et la véritable
égalité
je ne crois pas que notre école où notre
santé connaissent les mêmes défis dans
le centre de paris dans les quartiers de
cayenne ou dans un village au bord de la
vie
nous consulterons plus encore les corps
intermédiaires les forces vives notre
pays les françaises et les français de
chaque territoire
plus que jamais nous mènerons chaque
réforme en lien étroit avec les
organisations syndicales et patronales
nous avons besoin d'elles et elles
savent qu'elles trouveront en moi
lien à locutrice france constructive et
déterminé
associer toutes les forces vives du pays
dans un dialogue renouvelé et en
partageant les opportunités comme les
contraintes c'est le sens du conseil
national de la refondation
voulue par le président de la république
les français nous attendent
ils n'accepteront ni immobilisme ni
obstruction ni invectives ils veulent un
gouvernement et un parlement d'action
nous avons une responsabilité historique
vis-à-vis de nos concitoyens
responsabilité dans la manière d'agir
dans les réponses à apporter dans les
réponses à offrir
alors à partir du cadre qu'ont choisi
des français je vous propose de bâtir
ensemble
notre premier défi je sais que cela fait
consensus parmi nous c'est de répondre à
l'urgence du pouvoir d'achat
sous l'impulsion du président de la
république de nombreuses mesures ont été
prises depuis l'automne dernier pour
protéger les français de l'augmentation
des prix
sans elle les prix de l'électricité
pourraient augmenter d'un tiers grâce à
elle la hausse a été limitée à 4% sans
elle les prix du gaz devraient augmenter
de 45% grâce à elle les prix ont été
bloqués sans elle un plein de 60 litres
coûterait 11 euros de plus
nous avons réalisé un investissement
rapide et massif pour le pouvoir d'achat
les français grâce à lui notre inflation
est la plus faible de la zone euro
nous avons protégé les français et nous
allons continuer car beaucoup de nos
concitoyens reste à la merci de chaque
hausse des prix dès demain le
gouvernement présentera en conseil des
ministres des textes d'urgence face à
l'inflation ils comporteront des mesures
concrètes rapides efficaces nous vous
proposerons de prolonger de boucliers
tarifaires sur les prix du gaz de
l'électricité
d'augmenter les revenus du travail et de
mieux partager la valeur en baissant les
charges les indépendants et en triplant
le plafond de la prime pouvoir d'achat
nous vous proposons de revaloriser des
retraites et les prestations sociales
notamment les allocations familiales
la prime d'activité les apl
l'allocation adulte handicapé nous vous
proposons de revaloriser les bourses sur
critères sociaux nous vous proposons
d'aider les travailleurs pour lesquels
la voiture est une nécessité
ces mesures c'est notre base de travail
avec le gouvernement
nous serons à votre écoute et nous les
amendes rond quand des convergences
émergents
au-delà de l'urgence pour la plupart des
français le logement et la première
dépense nous voulons qu'ils soient
abordables pour chacun nous avons décidé
d'un plafonnement de la hausse des
loyers nous proposeront de nouvelles
solutions pour que le logement soit
accessible partout en ouvrant la caution
publique aux classes moyennes en
construisant davantage de logements dans
les zones en tension
en concluant un pacte de confiance avec
les acteurs du logement social
en proposant aux collectivités un nouvel
acte de décentralisation
pour concentrer les moyens et les
responsabilités à l'échelle des bassins
de vie tout en étant exigeant pour
qu'elle permette au projet de sortir de
terre le pouvoir d'achat c'est aussi
garantir à tous l'accès à une
alimentation saine
irons avec les professionnels avec les
associations avec vous les contours du
chèque alimentation
le pouvoir d'achat c'est venir en aide
aux plus vulnérables
nous voulons que chacun perçoivent les
aides auxquelles il a droit avec la
choisit d'arrêter à la source nous
mettrons fin à l'injustice sociale de
non recours et nous lutterons plus
efficacement contre la fraude
mais je veux l'affirmé les deux clés du
pouvoir d'achats durables c'est le plein
emploi et c'est la transition écologique
sur tous ces sujets je suis convaincu
que nous pouvons trouver des solutions
communes mais deux devront garder en
tête trois principes la responsabilité
environnementale d'abord nous devons
prendre en compte l'impact
environnemental de toutes nos mesures et
remplacé dès que possible nos dépenses
en faveur des énergies fossiles par des
solutions décarbonés
la responsabilité budgétaire ensuite
les mesure massives que nous avons mises
en oeuvre ont protégé des français il
fallait les prendre mais aujourd'hui
nous devons retrouver des perspectives
pour l'amélioration de nos comptes
publics c'est une nécessité pour
continuer à financer notre modèle social
c'est un devoir vis-à-vis des
générations futures une déclaration de
politique générale
c'est un moment de vérité un moment de
partage aussi des contraintes auxquelles
nous faisons face
les données sont claires du fait de la
guerre qui dure et comme partout en
europe notre croissance sera plus faible
que prévu l'inflation sera plus forte et
la charge de la dette augmente nos
objectifs eux aussi sont claires en 2026
nous devrons commencer à baisser la
dette publique en 2027 nous devrons
ramener le déficit public sous les 3%
ses objectifs
nous les atteindrons en bâtissant les
conditions d'une croissance forte et
durable qui créera des emplois en menant
les réformes nécessaires
en prenant des mesures de bonne gestion
et en accentuant la lutte contre les
fraudes
l'équilibré de nos finances publiques
est une question de souveraineté
je sais que beaucoup ils sont attachés
sur ses bancs
enfin notre troisième principe c'est le
respect termes de l'engagement pris par
le président de la république devant les
français pas de hausse d'impôt
nous devons cesser de croire qu'à chaque
défi la solution est une taxe alors pas
de hausses d'impôts nous sommes
crédibles nous avons supprimé la taxe
d'habitation baisser l'impôt sur le
revenu diminué les impôts des français
et des entreprises de plus de 50
milliards d'euros pendant le précédent
quinquennat
dès cet été nous tiendrons parole la
suppression de la redevance
audiovisuelle permettra de faire
économiser 138 euros à plus de 20
millions de foyers
elle ira de pair avec une réforme du
financement de l'audiovisuel public qui
garantira son indépendance et des moyens
pérennes nous y travaillerons ensemble
la fiscalité sera un de nos terrains de
débat mais elle peut être aussi un sujet
de consensus entre nous
j'ajoute que le pouvoir d'achat est un
combat collectif
chacun doit y prendre sa part et
notamment les entreprises qui dégagent
des marges au moment où l'inflation est
forte j'attends des employeurs qui le
peuvent qu'ils prennent leurs
responsabilités
nous pouvons nous devons aller plus loin
en la matière
notre deuxième défi c'est de bâtir la
société du plein emploi c'est une
conviction qui m'anime profondément une
conviction nourri par mon parcours par
deux ans comme ministre du travail par
nos échanges et parce que j'ai avec le
concitoyen
nous devons changer notre rapport au
travail et le coeur de ce changement
c'est le plein emploi ce n'est pas une
illusion ce n'est pas un objectif
inatteignable aujourd'hui de plein
emploi est à notre portée et le travail
reste pour moi un levier majeur
d'émancipation
lors du précédent quinquennat nous avons
déjà parcouru la moitié du chemin vers
le plein emploi nous avons le taux de
chômage le plus bas depuis 15 ans le
taux de chômage des jeunes le plus bas
depuis 40 ans la part des français qui
on travaille n'a jamais été aussi élevé
depuis que la mesure
c'est le résultat des réformes de fond
que nous avons menée pendant cinq ans
nous avons déverrouiller l'apprentissage
avec plus de 700000 apprentis en 2021
nous avons rendu le travail toujours
plus incitatif avec la restant de
l'assurance chômage
nous avons amélioré et intensifier la
formation de demandeurs d'emplois en
investissant 15 milliards d'euros dans
la formation professionnelle
nous accompagnons mieux les jeunes mais
grâce au plan un jeune une solution et
aux contrats d'engagement jeunes c'est
grâce à ce bilan que nous pouvons
désormais viser le plein emploi
j'ai la conviction profonde que notre
pays doit et peut sortir du cercle
vicieux du chômage de masse
aujourd'hui la situation de l'emploi a
changé dans notre pays de nombreuses
entreprises dans toutes les filières
dans tous les métiers dans tous les
territoires cherche à recruter cette
situation a des vertus elle impose aux
employeurs d'améliorer les conditions de
travail de questionner leur mode de
management et devrait à l'attractivité
de leur métier avec le plein emploi des
travailleurs retrouvent le pouvoir de
négocier et pour atteindre le plein
emploi nous devons aussi ramener vers
l'emploi celles et ceux qui sont les
plus éloignés du marché du travail je
pense bien sûr aux jeunes nous
continuerons accompagnés mais je pense
aussi aux bénéficiaires du rsa
ce que nous voulons c'est leur permettre
de retrouver un travail
comme le disait michel rocard ne perdons
pas la volonté tenace de l'insertion
revenons à l'esprit du rmi et du rsa
verser une allocation
ne suffit pas ce que nous voulons c'est
que chacun s'en sortent et retrouve sa
dignité grâce au travail ce que nous
proposons
ce n'est ni plus ni moins qu'une mesure
de justice sociale et d'équilibré entre
les droits et les devoirs
le plein emploi nous l'atteindrons aussi
en accompagnant mieux les chômeurs
aujourd'hui notre organisation est trop
complexe son efficacité en pâtit nous ne
pouvons plus continuer à voir d'un côté
l'état qui accompagne les demandeurs
d'emploi et de l'autre des régions qui
s'occupent de leur formation et les
départements en charge de l'insertion
des bénéficiaires du rsa
c'est pour cela que nous voulons
transformer pôle emploi en france
travaillent nous devons joindre nos
forces
travailler ensemble pour être plus
efficace dans l'accompagnement des
chômeurs c'est comme ça que chaque
français trouvera sa place sur le marché
du travail et que nous répondrons aux
besoins de recrutement des entreprises
le plein emploi c'est aussi relever le
défi de la découverte des métiers de
l'orientation et de la formation
cela commence dès l'enseignement
secondaire
avec les collectivités nous ferons en
sorte que chaque élève puisse découvrir
et connaître des métiers notamment de
l'artisanat l'industrie du tourisme des
métiers d'art nous élargirons au lycée
professionnel le succès de
l'apprentissage nous devrons dans le
supérieur permettent que les étudiants
choisissent et se lance dans une voie en
fonction du métier qu'ils veulent
exercer
grâce à la formation tout au long de la
vie nous voulons qu'ils puissent se
sentir libres d'en changer et de saisir
de nouvelles opportunités
grâce à cela ces prochaines années nous
pourrons former un million de jeunes
dans les métiers d'avenir dont la moitié
dont le numérique
enfin c'est grâce au plein emploi que
nous créerons de la richesse et que nous
pourrons financer notre modèle social
vous le savez nous avons toujours dit
les choses clairement aux françaises et
aux français
notre modèle social est un paradoxe à la
fois l'un des plus généreux est l'un de
ceux où l'on travaille le moins
longtemps
notre système de retraite est une
exception alors que l'on part plus tard
chez la totalité de nos voisins
européens
alors je le dis aujourd'hui pour la
prospérité notre pays et la pérennité de
notre système de répartition
pour bâtir de nouveaux progrès sociaux
pour qu'aucun retraités avec une
carrière complète est une pension
inférieure à 1100 euros par mois pour
sortir de situations le même métier ne
garantit pas la même retraite nous
devrons travailler progressivement un
peu plus longtemps
notre pays a besoin d'une réforme de son
système de retraites elle ne sera pas
uniforme et devra prendre en compte les
carrières longues et la pénibilité t
elle devra veiller au maintien dans
l'emploi des seniors le gouvernement la
mènera dans la concertation avec les
partenaires sociaux en associant les
parlementaires le plus jeune en haut
possible elle n'est pas ficelé elle ne
sera pas à prendre ou à laisser mais
elle est indispensable
j'ajoute que je ne peux pas que nous ne
pouvons pas nous résoudre à la
pénibilité de certains métiers par
l'innovation par la technologie par
l'évolution des carrières nous pouvons
nous devons améliorer les conditions de
travail et faire en sorte que nos
compatriotes ne finissent plus leur
carrière brisée oui le travail est une
valeur essentielle le travail c'est la
clef de l'émancipation c'est la création
de richesse la liberté d'entreprendre le
partage de la valeur des ressources
complémentaires pour notre modèle social
une ambition plus forte dans la
responsabilité sociale et
environnementale des entreprises nous
avons tous à y gagner
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
bâtir ensemble c'est apporter des
réponses radicales à l'urgence
écologique
devant le défi il n'est plus question
d'opposer des radicaux aux partisans
d'une écologie des petits pas tous nous
avons conscience des enjeux et des
risques tous nous devons faire bloc
ce mot de radicalité je le prends donc à
mon compte nous engagerons des
transformations radicales
d'autres manières de produire de nous
loger de nous déplacer de consommer mais
je la firme je ne crois pas un instant
que cette révolution prix matic passe
par la décroissance
au contraire
la révolution écologique que nous
voulons mener ce sont des innovations
des filières nouvelles des emplois
d'avenir c'est un modèle social
préserver car sans activité ne pourrions
plus de financer au cours des cinq
dernières années nous avons accéléré la
baisse des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre mais nous devons faire plus sous
l'impulsion de la france l'europe s'est
fixée l'objectif d'être neutre en
carbone en 2050 et de réduire les
émissions de 55 % d'ici 2030 ces
objectifs nous devons les acteurs
ensemble nous gagnerons la bataille du
climat
pour y parvenir tout le gouvernement est
mobilisé chaque ministre aura une
feuille de route crima et biodiversité
nous allons définir ensemble un plan
d'action un plan de bataille dès le mois
de septembre
nous lancerons une vaste concertation en
vue d'une loi d'orientation énergie
climat filière par filière
territoire par territoire nous
définirons des objectifs de réduction
d'émissions des étapes et des moyens
appropriés
la transition écologique l affaire de
tous
les dirigeants des grandes entreprises
doivent montrer l'exemple et leur
rémunération dépendra de l'atteinte des
objectifs environnementaux
nous avancerons avec les locaux ils ont
en charge l'aménagement du territoire
les transports l'habitat les déchets
nous avons besoin d'eux et c'est le sens
même de la création d'un ministère de la
transition écologique de la cohésion des
territoires
ils seront également des sources
d'inspiration d'initiative et d'idées
bien souvent dans leur territoire ils
ont montré le chemin
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs nous
voulons être la première grande nation
écologique à sortir des énergies
fossiles
cela garantit notre souveraineté
énergétique
c'est la préservation de pouvoir d'achat
ce sont des filières industrielles
nouvelles et des emplois créés car je le
dis je le répète notre écologie
est une écologie de progrès je sais que
cette transition peut parfois provoquer
des craintes notamment des salariés des
secteurs en mutation mais nous ne
laisserons personne sur le bord de la
route nous avons retenu les leçons du
textile et de l'acier chaque transition
ira de pair avec un accompagnement pour
la formation et la reconversion
pour sortir du carbone nous nous
doterons d'un mix énergétique équilibré
autour des énergies renouvelables et du
nucléaire
nous accélérons le déploiement des
énergies renouvelables nous investirons
dans le nucléaire avec la construction
de nouveaux réacteurs et des innovations
pour nucléaire du futur
la transition énergétique passe par le
nucléaire je sais que c'est une
conviction largement partagé sur ses
bancs c'est une énergie décarbonée
souveraine et compétitive et réussir la
transition énergétique
c'est pouvoir la piloter
je disais il ya quelques instants que
l'urgence climatique impose et des
décisions fortes radical nous devons
avoir la pleine maîtrise notre
production d'électricité et de sa
performance
nous devons assurer notre souveraineté
face aux conséquences de la guerre et
aux défis colossaux à venir
nous devons prendre des décisions que
sur ses bancs même d'autres on peut
prendre avant nous dans une période de
l'histoire ou le pays devait être aussi
gagné la bataille de l'énergie et de la
production
c'est pourquoi je vous confirme
aujourd'hui l'intention de l'état de
détenir 100% du capital d'edf
cette évolution permettra à edf de
renforcer sa capacité à mener dans les
meilleurs délais des projets ambitieux
est indispensable pour notre avenir
énergétique
réussi la transition énergétique s'est
ensuite consommer moins
si notre pays est moins dépendants du
gaz russe que nos voisins de ne pouvons
pas croire ou faire croire les décisions
unilatérales de la russie nous
épargnerait si la rue s'ils venaient à
couper
ses exportations de gaz nous serions
tous chez nous aussi dès maintenant nous
devons donc envisager tous les scénarios
concrets même les plus difficiles et
partager leurs conséquences avec les
acteurs et les français nous pouvons
tenir mais chacun devra agir
plus largement nous devons éviter toutes
les consommations inutiles notamment
dans le domaine du logement nous
amplifierons donc le succès de ma prime
rénove pour rénover 700 mille logements
par an
nous voulons permettre à chacun d'avoir
accès à des transports propres
cela vaut partout en ville comme dans la
ruralité
le ferroviaire est et restera la colonne
vertébrale d'une mobilité propre
nous continuerons les investissements de
ces dernières années pour les transports
du quotidien pour les petites lignes je
veux ici rendre hommage à l'action de
jean castex infatigable voix des
territoires qui s'est engagé
personnellement pour le ferroviaire
partout des solutions alternatives à
l'usagé individuel de voitures
thermiques devront être construites par
tous nous devrons continuer à soutenir
les mobilités propre et active
nous souhaitons permettre aux français
d'avoir accès en voiture zéro émission
pour y parvenir nous prolongerons les
aides à la conversion et nous mettrons
en place un système de location de
longue durée à moins de 100 euros par
mois c'est un projet écologique c'est
aussi une ambition industrielle car nous
construirons ces voitures électriques en
france
au delà des transports partout nous
allons décarbonée
c'est vrai notamment dans l'industrie
nous appuyant sur les 50 milliards
d'investissements de france 2030 la
moitié au moins sera consacrée à ces
enjeux cela vaut aussi pour
l'agriculture en continuant à
transformer notre modèle agricole
protéger l'environnement s'est enfin
préserver la nature et la biodiversité
face au risque d'une sixième grande
extinction
nous accentuerons entre politique de
préservation des espaces naturels forêts
montagnes toro océans nous aurons une
attention toute particulière pour nos
outre-mer dans la biodiversité est un
trésor inestimable
nous devrons enfin poursuit une autre
sortie la société du gaspillage et du
tout jetable il faut du réemploi de la
réparation de recyclage cela crée de
l'activité et du pouvoir d'achat
les outils ont été mises en place lors
du précédent quinquennat il faut
maintenant pleinement sont emparés vous
le voyez derrière les mots derrière des
engagements l'urgence nous impose des
actes rapides tout ne viendra pas de
l'état seul chacun devrait y prendre sa
part c'est la condition de la réussite
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
nous refusons une société où la vie et
les destins sont rasées selon le
quartier où l'on naît selon le lieu où
l'on vit selon la couleur de sa peau ou
la profession de ses parents
alors au coeur de l'engagement du
président de la république et du
gouvernement se trouve une volonté
briser les inégalités de destins
n'accepter aucune assignation social ou
culturel
permettre à chacun de choisir son avenir
tracer les chemins de l'émancipation
la république de l'égalité des chances
construit dès la naissance
l'enfant sera une priorité de ce
quinquennat dans la droite ligne du
chantier des 1000 premiers jours nous
répondrons à la première préoccupation
des parents aujourd'hui le manque de
solutions de garde pour les enfants et
notamment les enfants de moins de 3 ans
pour réussir le gouvernement serait de
bâtir avec les collectivités un
véritable service public de la petite
enfance il permettra d'offrir les deux
cent mille places d'accueil manquantes
nous voulons des solutions proche des
domiciles accès si financièrement nous
viendront en aide en priorité à ceux qui
en ont le plus besoin les parents qui
élèvent seules leurs enfants le plus
souvent des femmes pour eux pour elle
nous continuerons à bâtir un
accompagnement global avec les pensions
alimentaires désormais directement
versés sur les comptes en banque nous
avons franchi une étape majeure nous
continuerons et nous accorderons une
aide aux familles monoparentales pour la
garde des enfants jusqu'à douze en
bâtir la république de l'égalité des
chances c'est agir en priorité pour
l'école et la jeunesse c'est un chantier
essentiel
nous continuerons la refondation de
l'école entamée lors du dernier
quinquennat
notre école c'est celle qui conforte les
savoirs fondamentaux lire écrire
compter
respecter et s'emparer de nouveaux
savoirs comme le codage informatique
notre école c'est celle qui garantit
l'égalité ne renonce jamais à
l'excellence nous devons pousser sac
élèves à se dépasser
d'autres écoles nous devons aider les
jeunes à déceler et faire éclore ces
talents et aux adultes de les déceler
même s'ils ne sont pas dans le moule
former des millions de jeunes s'adapter
aux personnalités de chacun c'est le
défi auquel font chaque jour face les
professeurs notre école doit donc être
celle qui offre aux enseignants la
reconnaissance et la place qu'il mérite
les enseignants sont le coeur battant de
la république grâce à leur mobilisation
durant la crise sanitaire ils ont permis
à notre école de rester ouverte nous
devons au mieux les associer la
transformation de l'école nous
valoriserons leur salaire et
construiront avec eux les évolutions de
leur profession
avec eux nous devons bâtir un nouveau
pacte répondre à la question des
remplacements avancé pour l'aide
individualisée adapter leur formation
soutenir des projets collectifs mais il
serait illusoire de croire que les
solutions seraient identiques partout
sur tous les territoires
l'égalité réelle cette adapter notre
action en fonction des situations
locales et des besoins des élèves le
plan marseillan grand lancés par le
président de la république année
dernière a ouvert la voie nous donnerons
donc des marges de manoeuvre aux
établissements pour s'adapter nous
mobiliserons toute la communauté
scolaire les associations les élus car
l'émancipation de nos jeunes passe par
l'école mais aussi par le sport la
culture l'engagement
l'égalité réelle nous la construirons
dans le dialogue avec toutes les parties
prenantes
cette concertation sera lancée dès
septembre
notre jeunesse doit également continuer
à faire vivre les valeurs républicaines
le gouvernement continuera à déployer de
service national universel
l'avenir d'autres jeunesse enfin passez
par avance et dumont supérieur et de
recherche avec les moyens de ses
ambitions
l'université française est une chance
précieuse elle forme et guise d esprit
et là sur la transmission et le progrès
des savoirs dans tous les champs de la
connaissance
l'université sera donc au coeur de
l'action de notre gouvernement
nous améliorerons les conditions de vie
et d'études de nos jeunes nous
renforcerons l'égalité d'accès de
réussite en particulier dans le premier
cycle universitaire et nous
simplifieront le système de bourses
étudiantes
l'avenir de notre jeunesse s'est aussi
accompagné toutes les voix de
l'émancipation
assumons d'être une nation culturelle de
la culture chauffe la culture
grandissent la culture fait l'âme et le
rayonnement de notre pays
rendons la culture accessible à toutes
et tous des la jeunesse nous proposons
d'étendre le pass culture dès la 6è et
d'amplifier éducation artistique et
culturelle
soutenant la création dans l'espace
physique comme numérique prolongeons
notre action pour sauvegarder le
patrimoine c'est notre identité c'est
notre histoire c'est notre héritage
bâtissons une nation sportive le sport
donne sa chance à tous
offrons donc à chaque élève en primaire
trente minutes de sport par jour et
faisons des jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de 2024 un accélérateur de
l'activité physique dans notre pays
bâtir la république de l'égalité des
chances c'est aussi offrir à toutes et à
tous une santé de qualité
les français le savent et nous le disent
nous faisons face à un manque criant de
professionnels de santé cette réalité ne
pouvons ni la nier ni l'occulter si nous
avons supprimé le numerus clausus en
2018 nous devons aussi dire les choses
cette situation durera encore plusieurs
années
face à ce défi nous devons activer tous
les leviers
le premier c'est la prévention trop
souvent à tort on résume la santé aux
soins la prévention ce sont des
campagnes de santé publique des
dépistages des bilans de santé au moment
clé de notre vie mais bien au delà ce
doit être une vision des politiques
publiques prévenir les maladies c'est
agir sur la qualité de l'air sur
l'habitat sur les conditions de vie
c'est prendre en compte les inégalités
sociales qui sont aujourd'hui les
principaux déterminants de la santé de
chacun c'est pourquoi avec le président
de la république nous avons souhaité que
le gouvernement comprenne un ministre de
la santé et de la prévention
c'est un défi que l'état ne peut pas
relever seul nous travaillerons avec les
élus en particulier les maires qui sont
nos partenaires privilégiés
enfin nous devons soutenir nos soignants
le coc vida mise à jour les fragilités
notre système de soins il a aussi montré
l'engagement exceptionnel de soignants
et je veux ici leur rendre hommage
c'est d'abord grâce à eux que notre pays
a tenu notre devoir est de continuer à
agir
le ségur de la santé a permis des
revalorisations sans précédent des
rémunérations des soignants et des
moyens inédits pour notre hôpital
pourtant tout n'est pas réglé loin de là
nous avons pris des mesures d'urgence
pour cet été
l'heure est maintenant aux solutions
structurantes nous devons renforcer
l'attractivité des métiers permettre aux
choyant de passer plus de temps auprès
des patients en allégeant la charge
administrative en renforçant la
coopération entre les professions de
santé en investissant son innovation
pour moderniser notre système de soins
devons construire dans chaque territoire
une offre de santé adaptés
je suis convaincu que les solutions
viendront des professionnels des élus
des patients et du terrain dès septembre
des concertations seront lancés partout
en france avec un objectif clair lutter
contre les déserts médicaux par une
meilleure coordination entre les acteurs
entre la ville et l'hôpital entre le
public et le privé
je veux ici aussi rappelé que l'épidémie
de covin n'est pas terminée et qu'elle
reprend nettement ces derniers jours si
notre système de santé est aujourd'hui
préservée nous devrons rester vigilants
et prêts à y
bâtir la république de l'égalité des
chances c'est faire de la france un pays
où l'on vieillit bien un pays qui
favorise l'espérance de vie en bonne
santé qui assurent une prise en charge
de qualité à domicile ou en maison de
retraite
notre première mission c'est de donner
aux personnes âgées la capacité de
vieillir sereinement chez elle nous y
parviendrons avec le dispositif ma prime
adapteront leur permettre d'aménager
leur logement nous y parviendrons en
améliorant la qualité des services à
domicile
mais il nous faut aussi améliorer la vie
de nos aînés en maison de retraite
les scandales récents sont révoltants
nous avons renforcé des contrôles pour
qu'il ne puisse plus survenir nous
devons maintenant inventer les
établissements de demain plus ouvert
plus humain mieux médicalisé nous
devrons construire des liens plus forts
entre établissements et domicile créé
des ehpad hors les murs pour une prise
en charge plus adaptée de chaque
situation les investissements du ségur
ont été une étape majeure pour cette
transformation nous devons aussi relevé
le défi l'attractivité pour permettre le
recrutement de 50 mille infirmiers et
aides soignants d'ici 2027
lors du précédent quinquennat nous avons
créé la cinquième branche de la sécurité
sociale nous avons posé les fondements
du financement de cette nouvelle
d'arrêter nationale pour le grand âge là
encore avec les départements je vous
propose de travailler ensemble et de
bâtir un service public efficace qui
répondent aux besoins des personnes
âgées des familles au plus près des
territoires
bâti à la république de l'égalité des
sens c'est reconstruire une société
inclusive le handicap ces 12 millions de
français c'est un conjoint un parent un
enfant tout aux familles sont concernées
offrez leur une société qui accepte qui
inclut qui respectent une conférence
nationale du handicap se tiendra début
2023 nous agirons pour l'accessibilité
universelle
pour l'autonomie des personnes
handicapées notamment financières pour
la transformation des structures médico
sociales
pour une meilleure reconnaissance des
personnels de l'accompagnement nous
devons améliorer l'inclusion par le
travail dans le milieu ordinaire d'abord
ainsi que dans les esat ou une
entreprise adaptée
je vous annonce enfin que le
gouvernement réforme aura avec vous avec
les associations l'allocation adulte
handicapé il s'agira d'une réforme en
profondeur nous partirons du principe de
la dea conjugale isation c'est une
question de dignité est une avancée très
attendu
bâtir la république de l'égalité des
chances c'est réussir la cohésion des
territoires
nous voulons une relation fondée sur le
respect le dialogue et l'action je veux
saluer l'engagement et la détermination
des élus locaux je les dis les
politiques publiques doivent se
construire avec eux la crise sanitaire
la montre et quand nous travaillons main
dans la main nous pouvons tout surmonté
les cinq dernières années ont permis de
surmonter un certain nombre de fractures
en france nous avons créé plus de 2000
maisons france services seront investis
pour redynamiser les centres villes et
les centres bourgs et accélérer le
renouvellement urbain le gouvernement
poursuivra la logique de différenciation
partout où elles répondent aux attentes
la règle commune doit pouvoir s'adapter
en fonction des spécificités de chaque
territoire
nous voulons donner plus de poids aux
élus locaux plus de lisibilité de leurs
compétences plus de cohérence dans leurs
actions
le conseiller territorial
peut-être un moyen d'y parvenir
est de construire les complémentarités
indispensable entre départements et
régions
cela passera naturellement par des
concertations approfondies que nous
lancerons l'an prochain
pour mener à bien leur mission les
collectivités ont besoin de visibilité
de stabilité dans leurs compétences
c'est l'enjeu de l'agenda territoriale
que nous devons bâtir ensemble
état et collectivités
doit se donner une lecture commune des
défis à relever des leviers à activer
des moyens nécessaires
en corse
le cycle des discussions engagées avec
les élus et les forces vives sera
relancé dans les prochains jours il doit
aboutir à des solutions concrètes pour
tous les corses et notamment la jeunesse
des solutions concrètes pour le travail
pour le logement la transition
écologique pour le développement
économique et la sécurité
nous sommes prêts à ouvrir tous les
sujets y compris institutionnels allait
discuter en transparence dans un esprit
constructif et responsable mais ne s'est
donc pas la facilité répondons au cas
par cas à ceux qui bloquent ou
dysfonctionne
le gouvernement sera aussi celui de la
justice territoriale
quartiers prioritaires ou euros nos
territoires partagés défis communs bâti
dégradé manque de transports collectifs
accès à la santé à l'emploi sécurité de
tous les territoires de france j'entends
cette demande commune de justice de
cohésion de considération nous y
répondrons pour nos quartiers nous
bâtirons des solutions qui change le
quotidien et redonne des opportunités le
définiront les nouveaux contrats de
ville et répondront aux urgences avec
les habitants que les associations avec
les élus locaux nous mèneront des
opérations de renouvellement urbain est
essentielle car l'égalité commence par
l'état de sa rue de son hall d'immeuble
ou de son école
pour la ruralité nous continuerons à
investir
un nouvel agenda rural sera mise en
oeuvre
nous continuerons le déploiement de
france service pour garantir des
services publics de proximité et de
qualité aux habitants
nous lutterons contre la fracture
numérique
nous irons au bout la couverture mobile
en très haut débit d'autres territoires
nous accélérerons les formations
l'accompagnement aux usages numériques
la cohésion des territoires sont aussi
des fonctionnaires présents partout un
état qui répond vite et bien aux
demandes des français
c'est donner au fonctionnaire les moyens
de leur action nous continuerons la
modernisation de l'état
c'est offrir aux agents des trois
versants de la fonction publique une
reconnaissance et de meilleures
conditions de travail c'est le sens de
la revalorisation du point d'indicé la
plus importante depuis près de 40 ans
je veux aussi avoir un mot particulier
pour nos compatriotes d outre mer
les outre mer sont une chance
inestimable pour notre pays ce sont des
terres de jeunesse et d'espoir ce sont
les places fortes de notre souveraineté
plus que jamais nous avons besoin d'elle
pourtant ces derniers mois où j'avais
dit vos doutes vos craintes et vos
colères il ya quelques jours toutes les
collectivités d'outre-mer se sont
rassemblés pour lancer l'appel de
fort-de-france nous leur répondrons le
gouvernement les accompagnera pour
soutenir le développement économique et
créer de l'emploi pour renforcer la
présence des services publics et assurer
la sécurité pour améliorer la
distribution d'eau potable
l'assainissement le traitement des décès
pour agir sur toutes les causes de la
vie chère comme dans l'hexagone nous
devons avancer sur tous ces sujets
placer des outre-mer aux avant postes de
la transition écologique je demande à
tous mon gouvernement la plus grande
attention pour les territoires
ultramarins
ce quinquennat sera également celui
d'une nouvelle page autre histoire
républicaine avec la nouvelle calédonie
nous aurons à écrire l'avenir notre
relation au terme du processus politique
définie par l'accord de nouméa des
discussions seront engagées avec
l'ensemble des parties je veux ici
rendre l'hommage à l'action d'edouard
philippe figure du chances de l'état
face aux crises chacun connaît son
engagement pour l'avenir
de la nouvelle que les deux
bâtis à la république de l'égalité des
sens c'est agir pour notre sécurité
c'est une conviction qui m'anime
profondément car l'insécurité c'est une
inégalité
l'insécurité touche directement et je la
montre qui sont déjà fragilisées par la
vie ceux qui vivent dans des quartiers
où des zones où certains cherchent à
imposer leur loi face à celle de la
république le combat pour la sécurité
c'est donc un combat pour l'égalité
ce combat mon gouvernement le mènera
avec fermeté j'ai confiance dans nos
forces de l'ordre et j'ai le plus grand
respect pour elle c'est pour cela que
j'ai envers elle la plus grande exigence
et je le dis sans détour honte à ceux
qui attaquent systématiquement nos
policiers et de gendarmes honte à ceux
qui tente dressée des français contre
ceux qui les protègent
[Applaudissements]
nous voulons une gendarmerie et de
police républicaine au plus près des
français
les français veulent des réponses fortes
pour leur sécurité du quotidien les cinq
dernières années ont permis de donner
des moyens exceptionnels à nos forces de
sécurité intérieures nous avons recruté
dix mille policiers et gendarmes
supplémentaires nous avons fortifier
notre sécurité civile et agit pour nos
sapeurs pompiers nous avons renforcé
notre lutte contre le terrorisme et les
moyens de nos services de renseignement
en prolongeant l'effort entamé depuis
des attentats de 2015
le quinquennat qui s'ouvre doit nous
permettre d'amplifier cet effort autour
d'une vision globale et de moyens pour
notre sécurité
c'est pourquoi le gouvernement pour
proposera de loi d'orientation et de
programmation du ministère de
l'intérieur les défis sont nombreux
contre l'insécurité du quotidien contre
la cyberdélinquance contre les trafics
nous renforcerons encore les moyens de
notre sécurité
je sais ce qu'est le sentiment d'abandon
de certains territoires et la crainte de
voir la sécurité s'éloigner il ne doit
pas y avoir de zone blanche de sécurité
aussi nous engageons la création de 200
nouvelles brigades de gendarmerie ces
dernières années ont montré la nécessité
de mieux assurer l'ordre républicain
nous créerons 11 nouvelles unités de
forces mobiles
mais chacun le sait sur ses bancs les
français nous le disent la solution ne
se trouve pas uniquement dans des
effectifs supplémentaires
je me rappellerai toujours la colère des
familles et l'exaspération des forces de
l'ordre face aux multirécidivistes
la réponse c'est le refus de toute
impunité
nous doublerons le temps de présence des
forces de l'ordre ce terrain d'ici 2030
cela se fera grâce à nos recrutements en
allégeant les procédures et en les
modernisant une profonde réforme de
l'investigation sera mise en place avec
une formation plus longue le passage
obligatoire de l'examen d'officier de
police judiciaire et la création des
assistants d' enquête
la réponse c'est l'efficacité de la
justice ce sont des décisions rapides et
respecter les états généraux de la
justice lancée par le président de la
république ont montré qu'il fallait des
moyens supplémentaires et des méthodes
nouvelles qu'il fallait répondre à la
crise de confiance de concitoyens aux
attentes fortes des professionnels et
garantir toujours l'indépendance de la
justice le gouvernement vous proposera
donc une loi de programmation pour la
justice nous voulons recruter 8500
magistrats et personnels de justice
supplémentaire pour une justice plus
proche pour réduire les délais et
permettre aux juges de se concentrer sur
leurs missions fondamentales
nous agirons pour que chaque personne
chaque peine prononcée sera exécutée et
pour lutter contre la surpopulation
carcérale
une quarantaine d'établissements
pénitentiaires
15000 places seront livrés dans les
prochaines elle
je veux que nous ayons en lien étroit
avec les élus des associations des
magistrats les forces de l'ordre une
action toujours que résolu dans la lutte
contre les violences sexuelles sexistes
et les violences intra familiales
ce sera notre combat pour que les
victimes soit écouté protéger
accompagner pour que les plaintes soient
déposées et la justice dit c'est une
exigence absolue qui nécessite une
mobilisation absolue
enfin bâtir la république de l'égalité
des chances et porter nos valeurs les
défendre avec intransigeance
la liberté l'égalité la fraternité la
laïcité ne sont pas négociables
la laïcité est un pilier de notre pacte
républicain
face à elle le séparatisme et
l'islamisme sont des périls mortels
ils s'en prennent à notre unité
républicaine
ils sont le terreau de la radicalisation
et du terrorisme le gouvernement
continuera à le combattre de toutes ses
forces
l'égalité c'est refuser les
discriminations avec tout le
gouvernement nous serons pleinement
engagés pour l'égalité entre les femmes
des hommes allaient la grande cause du
quinquennat nous agirons dans tous les
domaines et notamment pour l'égalité
économique
nous lutterons avec intransigeance
contre toutes les discriminations
qu'elles concernent le genre la religion
la couleur de la peau le handicap
l'orientation sexuelle chaque
discrimination et une humiliation une
blessure une violence alors en
concertation avec tous les acteurs nous
continuerons à les prévenir et à les
sanctionner
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
je voudrais à présent vous parler de
notre souveraineté
la souveraineté ce n'est ni le repli sur
soi ni l'exclusion c'est notre capacité
à peser et à affronter les crises cette
souveraineté est à la fois profondément
française est profondément européen
la pandémie nous a prouvé notre trop
forte dépendance aux industries
étrangères
la guerre en ukraine nous a rappelé que
nous devions faire front pour faire
entendre notre voix
les crises migratoires nous ont montré
le besoin de solidarité européenne et la
nécessité de toujours mieux protéger nos
frontières
l'union européenne nous protège et nous
projette dans l'avenir une europe plus
forte c'est une france plus forte la
présidence française du conseil européen
a permis plus de 130 accord et autant de
réponses pour le climat le numérique
autonomie stratégique des droits sociaux
l'égalité femmes-hommes les défis la
souveraineté nous attendent bâtissons
ensemble ne france plus forte dans une
europe plus indépendante
ne france plus forte dans une europe
plus indépendante c'est la souveraineté
énergétique
ne pouvons plus dépendre du gaz et du
pétrole russes nous gagnerons notre
souveraineté grâce au nucléaire et aux
énergies renouvelables
une france plus forte dans une europe
plus indépendante c'est la souveraineté
industrielle et numérique nous sommes
sur la bonne voie par les baisses
d'impôts par la réforme du marché du
travail par l'attractivité retrouvée
nous avons mis un coup d'arrêt à
quarante années de désindustrialisation
maintenant accélérons
accélérons en continuant à tirer les
entreprises et des industries
comme annoncé par le président de la
république nous vous proposons de
baisser encore les impôts de production
et de supprimer la cvae des la loi de
finances 2023
concrètement ce sont près de 8 milliards
qui permettront de renforcer la
compétitivité de l'entreprise aux trois
quarts des pme et des eti
concrètement aussi nous compenserons
cette perte de ressources auprès des
collectivités
accéderont en investissant massivement
chez secteur d'avenir comme
l'alimentation l'énergie le spatial les
bio médicaments ou l'électronique
c'est le sens des 50 milliards d'euros
d'investissements de france 2030 pour
l'innovation pour la recherche pour la
réindustrialisation
nous investirons dans nos sites
universitaires nos organismes de
recherche nous continuerons à
revaloriser simplifier le métier de
chercheur
la recherche quel qu'en soit le domaine
inspiré fait la force d'autres pays je
veux rendre hommage à l'excellence de
nos universités et laboratoires et en
disant ces mots je veux féliciter au nom
du gouvernement le mathématicien hugo
duminil copains dans la médaille fields
fait la fierté de toute notre recherche
accélérons
en protégeant et promouvant notre
culture et notre création
accélérons aussi en tenant notre rang de
grandes nations numériques une nation
qui soutient sa femme steak nation
capable d'apprendre à ces jeunes les
bons usages
capable à travers la régulation de
lutter contre le cyber harcèlement et la
haine en ligne
ne france plus forte dans une europe
plus indépendante c'est notre
souveraineté alimentaire
le constat est édifiant près de la
moitié des agriculteurs prendront leur
retraite d'ici
2030 nous devons assurer l'avenir de la
filière agricole
la représentation nationale a déjà
montré autour de la question des
retraites qu'elles pouvaient s'unir pour
nos agriculteurs
alors bâtissons ensemble une loi
d'orientation et d'avenir pour
l'agriculture qui permettra de faire
émerger une nouvelle génération
d'agriculteurs
cela passe d'abord par une meilleure
rémunération par le soutien à la
transmission des exploitations
c'est la poursuite d'autres soutien
massif à l'adaptation de l'agriculture
au changement climatique avec
l'assurance récolte avec des moyens de
protection des exploitations c'est
l'investissement pour de nouvelles
productions les protéines végétales
notamment c'est la protection dans les
accords internationaux contre la
concurrence déloyale des pays qui ne
respectent pas nos critères sociaux et
environnementaux
c'est une politique d'alimentation qui
respecte chacun des acteurs et leur
donne une juste rémunération
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs une
frange plus forte en europe les
indépendances est également tenir nos
frontières au niveau européen nous
poursuivrons le travail entamé sous
présidence française pour renforcer
schengen pour des contrôles accrus aux
frontières de l'europe pour une
politique d'asile mieux coordonner au
niveau national
la france restera fidèle à sa tradition
désir et pour que cette politique soit
juste nous devrons poursuivre
l'accélération du traitement des
demandes à ce que nous accueillons nous
devons offrir une meilleure intégration
par le travail et nous devrons dans le
même temps reconduire plus rapidement ce
dont la demande d'asile a été refusée
pour y parvenir nous allons simplifier
et moderniser les procédures
je veux le dire aussi
disposer d'un titre de séjour en france
impose de respecter ses droits nous
serons intransigeants sur ce point en
matière d'immigration irrégulière nous
continuerons notre lutte à tous les
niveaux nous créerons une force des
frontières nous poursuivrons notre
combat contre les passeurs qui organise
de véritable trafic d'êtres humains ils
doivent être poursuivis et sanctionnés
ne france plus forte dans une europe
plus indépendante enfin c'est notre
souveraineté stratégique la guerre aux
portes de l'europe le maintien la menace
terroriste nous le rappelle nous devons
pouvoir nous défendre et faire entendre
notre voix au levant au sahel sur le
flanc est de l'europe sur terre dans les
airs sur les mers ou dans le
cyber-espace
partout dans tous les milieux nos armées
ce bac peintre liberté parfois au péril
de leur vie je veux dire à nos armées le
plein soutien et la confiance de
gouvernement et de la nation ici
représentés je veux leur rendre hommage
et avoir une pensée pour nos soldats
tombés au combat pour les familles
endeuillées et pour tous ceux revenus
des terrains d'opération meurtris dans
leur chair ou dans leur esprit
[Applaudissements]
le contexte géopolitique qu'il désordre
du monde nous oblige nous devons
disposer d'un modèle d'armée complet
équilibré moderniser un modèle d'armée
cohérent et capables d'agir le précédent
quinquennat a permis un effort sans
précédent depuis la fin de la guerre
froide pour nos armées nous avons
respecté l'exécution de la loi de
programmation militaire moderniser nos
infrastructures mener un renouvellement
massif de nos équipements et lancer les
grands programmes d'avenir comme celui
du nouveau porte avions nous devons
maintenant poursuivre et amplifier cet
effort prochainement le président de la
république annoncera les contours d'une
nouvelle loi de programmation militaire
il donnera une vision et un cap à nos
armées comme à notre industrie de
défense en tirant tous les enseignements
de l'engagement de nos forces et de la
coopération avec d'autres armes nous
tiendrons notre rôle nous agirons en
cohérence avec nos ambitions européennes
et nos alliés de l'otan
nous devons aussi fortifier la résidence
de la nation et par l'accroissement de
la réserve pour les actions pour notre
jeunesse le travail sur la mémoire par
l'attention portée à nos anciens
combattants nous renforcerons le lien
armée nation
la france sous l'impulsion du président
de la république devra enfin tenir sa
place soit scène internationale cela
veut dire plus d'efforts en matière de
solidarité internationale
une ambition accrue pour les défis
globaux comme la santé ou le changement
climatique
ça veut dire poursuivre le
renouvellement notre relation avec
l'afrique par le dialogue par les
partenariats par le travail de mémoire
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
je viens de vous présenter l'ambition
que porte le gouvernement
je voulais dire et le sort d'autres
travaillent à venir
mais les moyens de l'atteindre pourront
être enrichie amender les échanges
nourris menées avec les groupes de
l'assemblée nationale le montre nous
avons les moyens et la volonté de nous
retrouver autour de valeurs et
d'objectifs communs de construire
ensemble et de bâtir des majorités
d'idées l'heure n'est pas à nous conter
mais à nous parler la confiance se
décrète pas a priori
elle se forgera texte a pretext projet
après projet car nous travaillerons en
bonne foi et en bonne intelligence comme
le demandent les français
devant chaque défi nous devrons nous
poser la question où l'on nous bloquer
où l'on nous construire c'est en
fonction de cela que les français nous
jugeront
les enjeux devant nous sont immenses
mais je suis confiant et déterminé notre
pays est celui de tous les possibles
celui qui a surmonté les crises une à
une avec force et solidarité celui qui
refuse la fatalité
celui où la promesse républicaine peut
et doit avoir un sens et une réalité
cell conviction la première ministre
tient de son histoire de ce qu'elle doit
à la république c'est la république qui
lui a tendu la main en la faisant
pupille de la nation
c'est la république qui doit montrer que
le travail peut déjouer et destin tracé
c'est la république qui a ouvert la voie
à tant de femmes avant elle je pense à
irène joliot curie suzanne lacore et
cécile brune suite première femme en
d'un gouvernement en 1936 sous le front
populaire
je pense aux 33 première femme à faire
leur entrée dans cet hémicycle au
lendemain de la libération
je pense à simone veil dont la force et
le courage m'inspire à ce pupitre je
pense à edith cresson première femme à
accéder aux fonctions de premier
ministre
la première ministre en ce moment à
l'assemblée nationale présidé pour la
première fois par une femme c'est comme
chaque femme sur ses bancs ce qu'elle
doit à toutes celles qui ont ouvert le
chemin avant l heure
nous croyons à la force de l'exemple et
nous menons ce combat jusqu'à ce que
l'égalité ne pose plus de questions la
france notre france c'est celle des
enseignants qui donnent des visages et
des noms à la transmission et à
l'émancipation
la france notre france c'est celle des
soignants qui ne comptent pas leurs
heures et n'ont reculé devant aucun
effort pendant plus de deux années de
pandémie c'est les travailleurs de la
deuxième ligne qui ont assuré la
continuité de notre économie c'est les
commerçants qui ont été exemplaires qui
ont tenu ces sels notre jeunesse qui
nous met devant nos responsabilités
s'engage pour le climat prêt à se battre
contre destin commun c'est celle des
créateurs des entrepreneurs des
travailleurs des fonctionnaires des
artisans des agriculteurs
celle qui vient en aide à ceux qui en
ont besoin qui ne laisse personne sur le
côté étant toujours la main c'est celle
la solidarité l'engagement de la volonté
c'est aussi celle des craintes que nous
devons écouter les peurs auxquelles nous
devons répondre et aussi parfois des
colères que nous devons apaiser cette
france c'est la nôtre alors soyons à sa
hauteur à la hauteur des françaises et
des français une nouvelle page de notre
histoire politique s'ouvre nous allons
l'écrire ensemble devant vous je
m'engage à partager les enjeux et les
contraintes à vous faire part de nos
feuilles de route c'est des différentes
voies que nous prenions emprunter je
m'engage à ne jamais rompre le fil du
dialogue avec les groupes parlementaires
étaient forces vives avec les françaises
et des français je m'engage à bâtir des
compromis ambitieux sans compromission
sur les valeurs des solutions concrètes
des majorités de projets et d'idées les
français en sonné l'heure de la
responsabilité
nous serons au rendez vous nous avons
toutes et tous une part à prendre nous
avons tout pour y réussir
bâtir ensemble nous y parviendrons je
vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
monsieur ministres a acté donné que la
déclaration
du gouvernement dont il vient d'être
donné lecture au sénat
mais cheikh mes chers collègues je vais
suspendre la séance elle sera reprise à
21h pour la déclaration du gouvernement
suivie d'un débat en application de
l'article 50-1 de la constitution la
séance est suspendue